several weeks ago we got in a discussion
here on the air about a change in the
way you are using your debit card now
let me help you with this in the past
until just recently the way you've used
your debit card is this a credit card
has one function it functions as a
credit card period when you use it
you're in debt instantaneously as of
that moment has a magnetic strip on it
you slide it through you sign the paper
at the store and boom you've borrowed
money and you used your credit card you
did a transaction if you do that and if
someone steals your credit card number
and uses it fraudulently or as it does
an online transaction that's fraudulent
you are not liable visa covers you
against and your bank covers you against
credit card fraud you're not liable for
someone misusing stealing and misusing
your card number your debit card until
recently had two functions and there was
two distinct ways you could use your
debit card one was you use it like a
credit card and some of you can still do
that I still have a debit card that does
that and you just run it through bought
some stuff at Sports Academy the other
day and I'm like which button do I push
the green one of the red one to make it
credit I don't want to put in my pin and
I use it like a credit card but of
course as soon as the transaction is
completed the money is taken from my
checking account and there's no debt
involved if you do that you are running
your debit card transaction through the
visa system the MasterCard system and
you have the exact same exact same fraud
protections and online theft protections
and identity theft protections and all
of that someone misuses the number in
some way you didn't do the transaction
you simply are not liable your bank is
required by Visa to put the money back
posthaste
into your account and then they are to
track it down they either lose the money
or visa loses the money one of the two
but you don't lose the money the other
thing you can do with your debit card is
it brings it up and it says pin
and you enter your PIN number and until
recently what that meant was you were
about to leave the visa system and you
are going to enter the ATM system and
you're now using your debit card like an
ATM card it only then has the fraud
protection that your bank provides for
ATM transactions you're not in the visa
system okay that's the way it has been
for the entire time debit cards have
been in the United States until now and
it has recently begun changing and
there's a a chip being put onto the
debit cards that are is meeting what's
called the EMV guidelines and it is an
excellent thing in that your your
magnetic card has all your data on it
your magnetic strip does and soon no
card readers are going to use the
magnetic strip and therefore we're going
to lower identity theft and fraud
considerably because each time you use a
chip debit card it sends a different set
of numbers through to your bank and the
unique to that single transaction and
the store does not have your card number
the store does not have your information
they have just the information from that
transaction that the chip generates and
so it keeps like you know target got
breached and some what hundred million
people or whatever it was got their
stuff stolen and I'm exaggerating but as
a bazillion people got their stuff
stolen right and see target would not
even have had this stuff if we're they
were using EMV cards now EMV cards have
been very popular in Europe and Canada
for many years but they're just now
really forcing them on the states it's
not a regulations change it's a
marketplace change and so what is
happening now some of you have the EMV
cards with the chip on them and some and
a lot of the merchants now have readers
that only read the EMV cards and so if
you have a debit card that is an EMV
card has a chip on it one of the newer
ones and the merchant has new
transaction software and hardware you
put it in it's not going to give you the
chance to go debit or credit you're
going to type in a pin every time and
that doesnõt drop you outside into the
ATM transaction that leaves you in as a
Visa or MasterCard transaction so you've
got better technical mechanical
transaction protection and you've got
the same promises from visa and from
your bank with the EMV cards that you're
protected from fraud so you're going to
start seeing that more and more and more
because really by the close of this year
merchants who do not have the hardware
that processes the EMV cards the banks
are going to start holding the merchant
liable if there's a fraudulent
transaction and so the merchants are
upgrading fast to the EMV hardware so
the hardware that reads your card is
going to be a little bit different when
you they're not going to scan the
magnetic strip now you'll see the
magnetic strips on there for the next
two or three years probably
but the EMV the chip is what's going to
be doing the transaction more and more
and more every single day it's going to
add you're going to see this more and
more and more transactions and we've
seen it start popping up in our
neighborhood and honestly we didn't see
it but we didn't know what they were
doing it so we've done a bunch of
research on it dug into it I have
interviewed people in the banking
industry in the hardware industry in the
merchants side we've looked at the
regulations and looked at what these
what the data is that's driving this and
so forth and so I'm very very good stuff
we've got a very good article on all the
details on this if you want to see it
and understand what's going on that we
will be posting online soon I don't
think we've posted it yet have we okay
well when we post it remind me and I'll
tell everybody James and we'll get it
we're you know get this in one of our
blogs or something at Dave Ramsey comm
so you can read through it but so you
guys can understand what's going on
but there's always been the stuff that
people have lied about or they just were
stupid you know I don't use my debit
card I had a guy tweet this morning I
use my debit card because it doesn't
have the same fraud protections well yes
it does stupid as the exact same fraud
protections that's just dumb okay you
just believed a lie
and now it's going to be the exact same
fraud protections but you're going to be
using your PIN now which means I have
never used my PIN in my life I don't
even know what it is I'm going to have
to go find I'm going to reset it and
memorize a pin because I've never used
my debit card as an ATM card I stayed
within the visa system for the
protections number one also for the
convenience I just you know just run it
like you run a credit card I treated
just exactly the same way except I
actually have money and that's the only
difference and so um you know I've not
I've not fallen into that but now I'm
going to have to actually learn my PIN
number because of this EMV so as soon as
I get updated debit cards next go-round
when the bank sends them out and they
send them out every so often I'm sure
it'll have the EMV chips on it and once
the EMV chips are on there then we'll
you know we'll be doing that it stands
for europay MasterCard Visa is what AM B
stands for by the way so we're all going
to be on that system you're going to
know your PIN and you're going to have
Visa MasterCard protection when you use
your PIN with an EMV chip card you're
going to be okay this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind
you